yeah my watch says it's half of our
survival I'll completing good evening
everyone as we all know John has our
chair has moved away so as vice chair
I'm taking over the chair tonight it is
the last audit committee of this session
so um I was just a big pinion that I
would just ask perhaps something to take
over the vice chair just for tonight and
hope everybody of green I was going to
put forward Dave Merrick as vice chair
but drive a seconder and it's that grade
yes it's all right okay if you don't
mind David thank you right item one is
apologies for absence we have one
apology received in the office and that
is Councilwoman other anymore no
okay item number two non members
attending no item number three minutes
of the meeting held on the eights of
December 2015 do we have a great with
that design yes crazy seconded item
number for to receive declarations of
interest no right I've got to go back to
prior to the opening of the meeting
because I haven't done the emergency
evacuation announcement and I think I
should because there are some people
here that we've been here before so I
will go through this in the event of a
fire or other emergency please exit the
building in an orderly manner it to the
assembly point which is located in the
market car park
the fire exit in this room is indicated
by a green fire exit sign please do not
delay the evacuation by collecting any
belongings do not use the lift the
premises must not be reentered until the
Fire Brigades have given the all-clear
please note it is against the law to
smoke on these premises and please note
that this meeting will be audio recorded
so sorry about that I shall go back to
question item number five questions on
notice item number six motions or notice
right item number seven to consider the
report of the section 151 officer
drawing members attention to the grants
claim and return certification report
from the council's external auditor
thank you and this is our last report
and ever then I think Marco pilot number
of years of three appointed officers to
to the council and so it's our final
hope arrived for we hand over completely
to my so and I just want to say thank
you to everyone who's helped us over
last 17 years the kids since we're here
and we were pointed from from nineteen
ninety eight ninety and I joined what
was then p care on the person November
39 and this is one of the first councils
I came out to the who had long memories
the days of when Roger Crofts was yes
the director Dave Deeks was the head of
finance and Chris Mills who's now of
course of counsel point had just
provided as a an accountant and was
being lumped with a new way of
accounting for fixed assets which was
causing some slight issues so it's been
a long and we've gone through cuts with
odd number of different regimes that
since that point and so quite a lot of
things quite a lot of water in the road
and for me thank you very much and lots
of berries run through the report like
garage and settlement thanks for the
fish and we'd like to thank you that the
work you've done for the last 17 came
very much okay and so this report
relates to the work that we did on the
2014-15 and housing benefits subsidy
return so it is an annual piece of work
is something that would do each year and
the counts or submits a claim to the DWP
which just reflects the amount of
expenditure learning curve and housing
benefit and possibly and climb rocks
movie they and be reimbursed for that
expenditure that they've encouraged
during the financial year so this report
just summarizes the the findings from
that piece of work so I'd like to start
on page two empirical books seven point
six or more and so just at the very top
of the page there is a summary of the
high-level finding by the the total
value at the claim and that is
ultimately the amount of subsidy that
the council has claimed from the DWP
respect to housing benefits and was
eighteen point three million and the
return was qualified and it was amended
and I'll talk a little bit about that
shortly but ultimately the impact of
those amendments was 152 pounds increase
on the amount payable to the DWP's
obviously on eighteen point three
million that's not a significant amount
and buying stretch in terms of the
qualification and the amendment and the
detailed findings section provides some
information on those soldiers then go
through those briefly so moving on to
page three of the report bullet points
down the right-hand side there just
summarize the findings and
the issues that we have to be polite and
in terms of the first bullet point and
the the initial samples that we test so
we look at each different type of
benefit of the council page out and
retest the claims make sure that they've
been awarded in the columns with the
legislation to make sure that the
claimant income has been assessed
properly where that's appropriate and so
on so in this particular instance we
have identified two claims which had non
HRA expenditure and so basically these
are claimants that are being housed in
temporary accommodation so being the
least accommodation that type of setting
we identify two claims where some manual
adjustments had been made to the claim
but they'd actually be made incorrectly
so in order to address that we we had a
look at all of the claims which had been
subject to a similar manual adjustment
and we check to see whether they've been
put through correctly and as it says
there we are then to find further three
claims and where they had been incorrect
manual adjustments but we were able to
amend the return for those so ultimately
it was corrected the following bullet
point is to do with how particular types
of overpayment are classified so with
for whatever reason the council pays
over too much benefit to attainment that
has to be identified on the claim and
depending on anything for that
overpayment there they're classified in
a particular way so we identified a
particular instance where an overpayment
had been reclassified incorrectly and
the population of that type of
overpayment was what we define a small
so it was less than 100 claim so we were
able to look at all of those relatively
easy and just see if they were any more
issues there and pleased to say that no
further errands
identified respective that particular
matter and the third bullet point is a
similar issue the first one again it's
where manual adjustments were required
so officers had to go in physically make
a change on the system and because the
the software wasn't clever enough to do
it itself basically because of the
nature of the adjustment and again we
identified that some of these manual
adjustments had not been put through
correctly we were able to drill down and
identify the cases that were potentially
affected by that and again see if there
were any further errors and so the
remainder of the the narrative just
describes and the fact that we did
identify some further errors we were
able to correct some of those and for
the ones that we weren't able to correct
we reported those in the qualification
letter which is the letter that goes off
the vwp just explaining any particular
matters that we weren't able to address
qualification that is our relative a
common from emotion authorities that
have a housing benefit return to get a
qualification letter in it it simply
reflects the complex nature of housing
benefits it would be very unusual that
every single claim had been processed
completely correctly during during the
year because obviously there are
thousands of claims and thousands of
changes and so the fact there's a
qualification letter isn't isn't out of
the ordinary the penultimate bullet
point on page 43 start dates and how
they and they were determined we are
there to fight one area in our initial
sample and so we retested the further
for two cases now the number of
additional cases we test is its
prescribed by the methodology set by
what was the Audit Commission and now
psia and we focused on whether start
dates of claims have been input
correctly and again I'm pleased to say
we didn't identify any further errors in
relation to start dates on
and then finally we had to do some
additional work on a child tax credit
income which is something that can
impact on a subsidy claim the clemency
receipt of that then it can affect the
amount of housing benefit that they
rewarded we identified an issue in the
prior-year an hour test the water
testing approach prescribed testing
approach requires us to do some
follow-up work in the current year if
we're not able to confirm that actions
being taken that would completely
eliminating the error again the complex
nature of housing benefits means that it
is quite challenging to put something in
place they guarantee that I've error
that not happen again and so we did some
additional work again a further 40 cases
we did identified one error in this
particular instance the nature of the
claim and that it didn't have an impact
on the amount of benefit awarded and so
it wasn't classified as an error for
subsidy purposes it also we have no
impact on the amount of subsidy fined by
the count I have to take any questions
on those that is a bit of a whistle-stop
to a appreciators and quite a narrative
that if anyone has any questions on
those findings on yes first of all right
by you are mentioning which was across
playthings sir I didn't believe you
stick and you Steve classed as well of a
stupid efforts of the can support of
your life kind of a mistake Atlanta
teacher to do it later but anybody
started the minister thank you for your
presentation going back to page to our
testing room of initial songs with Fuji
cases identified five plane containing
ever now which alarms me because that
indicates that warning one in eight
whenever and yet the other have a high
level finding is you've got an overall
error
pounds out of 18 million I just wonder
why I should make of this would you
would you William first of all think but
12 and half percent is a little is a
loser estimate of the oval vehicle Emily
I think and in terms of fee just going
back 250 pounds versus the eighteen
point three million it's because of the
nature of with the subsidiary term and
housing benefits it can often be the
case that we may identify just over
twelve twelve percent error rate in
terms of a number of cases but actually
the monetary impact of that is often not
twelve percent of the total amount of
subsidy tight and that simply reflects
that kind of the complex calculations
that are involved in housing benefits
and so but that's why the to appear to
be disjointed if you like the 152 pounds
doesn't necessary feel quite right when
you look at the error rate yes I think
the other no doubt is that 152
represents an issue where we've
announced gets the bottom of every
single case of that nature and so we
have a directly quantifiable adjustment
to make so it's factual however the
certain area is where which are reported
here as well where we've identified a
number of errors but we can't ever
without testing absolutely everything
thousands of cases we cannot can't get
the position when we have an absolute
definitive value for error so we've got
an extrapolation so basically we take an
error rate amia we apportion across the
population those things are reporters
errors in in the qualification letter
but they aren't actually adjusted for so
the van the actual value of errors is
slightly higher than the bottom line and
perseverance quotes here unnecessarily
send to the error rate and very saying
it's not unusual to have
that if something has gone wrong in a
particular area it's not unusual for
something to have occurred you know that
a frequency that might look alarming
however is easily fixable and if you
look at the other ones the error rates
which are there are to be less than that
of that rate so I've done some exciting
terms of the apparent error rate that
particular issue and it doesn't
necessarily there's a systematic issue
for the whole population for all those
particular things okay um but when you
look to the sample there's 40 cases what
was that abandoned sample you looking to
the things no it's a it's a random
sample so the beginning sampling
methodology that we applies is
prescribed so what was your the
commission of psi actually provide us
with a set of instructions effectively
that we're required to follow so those
those initial 40 cases were picked at
random from a schedule of all of the
housing medical claims that are included
within the subsidy return and split
between two different evenly so 20 from
each type of benefit that the counselor
awards I'm worried but we're overpaying
I'm going to underpay specific service
will be underpaid know that I see here
the three cases of total value that most
modern pastry three cases total value of
expenditure Association benefit avoid
under pay those funds how much like my
tent allah and the last pallavaram
hastily you talk about the total value
of expenditure on these if i understand
it buddy with a five cases of a total
expenditure of 1196 pounds yeah and
errors on on these cases were once
number their sizable others in
comparison to that of 96 I'll be a leap
I don't know too much of ourselves
relate to are these two these cells
indicate money to be paid or my or
calculations of income
or feed the cells so when we talk about
so we're referring to the subsidy return
that the council submits to the DWP so
each of those cells has a specific
definition if you like and it relates to
a particular type of benefit expenditure
so the the values included in those
cells on the subsidy return reflect the
amount of money that the council has
paid out has actually spent during the
year on that particular category of
Housing Benefit so those in five cases
where the totem sponge 1196 these these
cells 102-103 1061 monthly they relate
to most fight racism yes I'll be a
combination so cells 102 and 103 and
reflects the same type of expenditure
paid out and then sells so 113 reflects
a particular type of overpayment so
where the council's identified that
benefit has actually been overpaid
before whatever so that could be where
the claimant has a told them that
they've had an increase in income for
example or there's been a delay of
notifying of another change in
circumstance but yes the the numbers
reflected there on each of those cells
reflect the errors identified in all the
five cases so it's across the five cases
thank you
Thank You Klaus you is there a common
thread I mean I was in you know if your
email very start dates but is there a
comment date that certainly areas don't
seem really seems to trigger out of
certain areas because either somebody's
not been trained properly or they don't
understand the interpretation or is that
just being a bit simplistic and really
as he's not as prescribed with that and
it starts revs for new benefit claims
and any changes of circumstance to an
existing benefit claim the way that they
are processed out quite clearly
prescribed and there is effectively a
set of rules that you need to apply
depending on the circumstances apply to
that particular claim and so if a start
date has been applied incorrectly so a
change of circumstance has not been
applied from the correct date for
example then it it might be oversight by
the benefit Assessor putting it in it
might be a misunderstanding of the rules
i mean what i should say is it comes
back to what they've said we didn't
identified lots of errors in relation to
start guides and again the nature of
housing benefits is such that you will
almost certainly find an instance where
something hasn't been done quite right
in just so much information process
rapidly for so many different benefit
claims and so i don't think there's any
a systematic error but where it does
happen then yes it accepted because
someone hasn't interpreted the rules
correctly I mean you you know from our
previous meetings we've expressed
concerns that we are trying to overload
the system we what we're inspecting to
pap produce what we expect of them I'm
trying to make sure that we're not going
down the road that we just perpetuating
this issue we've raised for
last meetings and actually we're not
getting to the root of the problem was
just carried on with this situation
because we're expecting our staff to do
too much or they're not getting the
right kind of all or whatever or whether
we should Jim should be picking some of
these other stuff up from internal audit
or where we're going or is it just
nobody's actually is quite reasonable
you can review for accounts of this diet
or an hour sighs and you know really you
know people who expect a certain
percentage of an error which I think
it's on something it's a good
questioning that's all thing we could do
fine as far as that you can bring temps
in to try and get rid caseloads and they
don't get it right and every single
thing they do happen to be wrong but but
in those of situations where can I slow
that population and then only look at
those particular cases but I think here
serving that the start dates we're not
looking something systemic I'm the
manual adjustments I think with more a
reflection about their two particularly
complicated maybe 70 cater on realistic
so in a particular situation you know
where we actually were able to make an
adjustment because we were ready to
isolate that particular population and
then that was some way where maybe some
extra training might've held okay other
the other is the start date this is none
it's not a systematic issue so really
rather to take that on board which
happened you worry about further down
the line that the perhaps there are
cases where we should be looking to do
it was more in-depth your comprehensive
or yeah I think I think I think like
most use it if is if there's something
whether a pattern what the manual
situation so that's something which can
be taken on board the other ones it's
just if it's just a lesser I rushing it
aware of how the payments are
identifiers already under blankets
problem particularly when it's error by
ourselves is there always corrected back
to the individual claims yes yeah when
it Sunday's was it simply good night
what about there isn't an overpayment
particularly where they've give us false
information principals who claims
cummins false information what happened
was they think you recover the money
from them we don't really have every
time via the police the Rangers have
replaced it to try an get the money back
it's not always successful because many
people to move you're not a minimal
amount that you would play with them
baggage they list Underpants okay I
think if it can I to that yeah they will
go up in value clearly it's at what
point is it economic or not to learn to
certainly start their start the search
to try and find them and then claim
about yessir and what would be the stage
where you would look like cuz you said
given wrong information that you would
look at fraud rather than a mistake I
don't know the value of the top of my
head but it's something we would
absolutely consider yeah it cooks book
value on it isn't it to be honest
because I was that people are going to
always try and just get up to that value
but there would be circumstances where
it would be considered this is a
deliberate again further about alluring
yeah she can tell you there is we
actually prosecuted are you there it's
not within our Emanuel's now over to dwp
but we have prosecutes and a symbol
any more questions on that we happy to
look at the recommendation then so
proposed that the committee resolves
that the grants claim when returns
Clarence it certification 2014-15 be no
to debris so iam we leave in peace what
is up to you um yes I mean you can go
make it an early night and we would just
like to say again thank you very much
it's been a pleasure doing business for
years yes yes be very helpful and he's
got billion just make even the committee
come back and visit again the old house
at some point yes thank you very much
ghost stories
right now I'm just remembers moving on
to other things this is just a dealing
with the outstanding recommendations
from the report the video back in
September 2015 all recommendations well
there's three recommendations to have
been implemented the only outstanding
one is on page 84 that is ongoing and
come in a dress and it will be English's
audit plan and have it say questions any
questions on this item is there
something we fundamentally will change
on this sporting don't monitoring of
their free zone this situation is it is
a bigger bigger of a release or
fundamental change or is it tweaking the
AG's have had fun I mean we had this
promise I shopping last time word where
this came up are we looking and that
this is just a refinement of the
operation or is there a again a
fundamental flaw in the setup there's no
fundamental
seed roses there's been recent changing
legislation as well a working group has
been set up as stated in there yeah I
think I defined on there's no time for
underfloor it's just changing working
masses any other questions but Willem
Frey's right here I tweet men yes I'm on
the appendix page open to being pestered
ones emasculation any ideas off of the
size of the approximate size of
standards so how's the marriage
something pollution on page eight
pointed yes one number one I got a
liability on collection fund accounting
it male any of the approximate value of
that I think I'm at you by believe it's
in the region of about three hundred
thousand and pounds we're sitting on as
a provision and so the one of these
principal accountant to the money was
looking into it would be made and the
government several times a night of
response got us a more proactive view
and there's go and give McCall gun
handsome and down to get definitive do
we owe this money or not
three hundred thousand pounds yes so I
can come and confirm the exact figure
that's not a lot of money Angela cookery
have a mum German would it be important
to off the tour comes back to this
committee if I may add to be honest I
wanna solve this before year end so that
we can you can wait until then but it
would be clear either way but it
probably I'd be very happy to see you
report in the next sitting here telling
us it will be clear though absolutely
yeah but we better clean up that less
pain feels ok but so if I just clarify
said three hundred thousands or even put
aside it's always been made a provision
has been right raised for this so if we
have to pay it from our financial
position our budget and everything next
year it's not an impact but clearly if
we don't have to pay it that's obviously
a better option right let's say I want
to corner say it's not something that is
completely unaware of we honorable never
maybe one day I for this one time and
that's what you're right I'll get any
exactly been on confirmed a report yes
mhm well I market went to my therapist
the next to the gears what's got for me
thank you absolutely would be possibly
living that matters mr. how situational
of waitin for this
so other than that Jefferson just taken
from from Chris in on the same page it's
just early photos statements you know
they're all silent if I back out of my
head but I think they're worth the fight
template to affect current arrangements
etc and simmer sauce statement the last
sentence in the subsequent I mean is
that all now in hand but what we is this
the working practices that those was
talking about I have just closed down
and for incidents like yeah financial
statement collection fund accounting it
says here we have also identify the
council have not adequately updated
their working paper template to reflect
current arrangements but County for
non-domestic rates and his goes in et
cetera discussing the central government
responsible officer in typical
accountant in animated februari and the
next one the stately included and
weaning complete cash flow statement and
drive version the summer they all
remember police midge raised both these
points are we down you know we covered
bug Lee's aspect now but aight is
implemented but absolutely I so dry yeah
yeah we are we're getting a lot touch on
that now Aereo and certainly the the
financial statement stuff so what we've
done we've implemented we cut five works
at the time table so fast because we
know by 2017-18 we've got to take three
months at the entire time yeah I know
these did you go so this week we've now
got a good time tag where a robust and
I'm holding the guys to it okay okay we
have to enough any further questions so
the recommendation that the updates
provided in the monitoring to cheat on
external early to recommendations
arising from the final audit reports the
Audit Committee for the year ended 31st
of mar 2015 be noted
item 9 external auditors annual audit
plan from you it is um so this is a
welcome rather than a goodbye thank you
very much and we are very happy to be
appointed as audiences and I'll start
with a quick introduction so I'm Kevin
souza an executive director for me why
so the designing partner for the work
and my colleague here's Chris you it
here is the audit manager for your audit
and honestly we are delighted to be
appointed as your auditors I hope at the
end of our tenure that we get such
positive words as our predecessors were
given just to just say a quick word
again be neo happy extremely helpful and
hand over arrangements they have
complied of all the necessary rules and
regulations a trim the mix by the Audit
Committee of the handovers and provided
a good briefing for us as have your
officers being very helpful in
developing our understanding the
authority I just like to place our
effects on record and for the officers
and their help in getting our work off
the ground so appendix 1 2 item 9 is our
annual plan or Alfred 1516 audit we set
out a number of points that we are
required to bring to your attention by
various rules and standards for auditing
and the the highlights would be the
risks are recognizing for the statement
of accounts and in terms of our value
for money responsibilities the risk of a
statement of accounts are set out on
page nine point seven of your pack and
and I think it would be fair to fetch
described them as fairly standard risks
that you will expect to see in a number
of comparative reports or other local
authorities auditing standards asked us
to look at various risks including a
revenue recognition and to make sure you
have the right income expenditure in the
correct year
we recognize that risk of this authority
and in particular we think the risk may
be prevalent given the understanding
your financial framework in whether
items of capital expenditure have been
properly capitalized or whether or not
they should be recognized as revenue we
also recognize in every audit plan as
naw deter that no matter how robust the
controlled environment may be management
are always in a very unique position to
be able to circumvent our control
environment so we exercise our
professional skepticism of the conduct
of all our audits and in particular we
look at journal entries as journals are
one with methodologies getting around
controls we look at accounting estimates
and we look at any unusual transactions
just to see if there's any indication
that management may be biased or
misreporting in those areas but the
inclusion of that in our plan should not
represent any inference ters those those
incidences are expected to be any higher
here than any other audit on page nine
point nine and we talk about our value
for money risks we go through a risk
assessment process under our
responsibilities to identify if there
are any Arrangements where we don't have
sufficient information at this point in
time to be able to give the correct
opinion what we're not saying here in
terms of rowlett plan is that there is a
definite risk to you that your
arrangements are not they bust it's
about the risk to us that would do we
know enough we've identified the risk
and then associated with your medium
term financial plan that there is a
sizable budget gap over the next few
years and we will be undertaking work to
understand the robustness of how the
budget was arrived at various
assumptions for example the inflation
assumptions that were made and then take
a look at the council's plans for
identifying the relative savings or
further income streams to plug that gap
over the next few periods
as I mentioned there are various aspects
that we do need to bring to your
attention and just give a highlight of
those as we go through section 4 and 5
in section 4.4 wished on page nine point
13 it's useful to bring to your
attention the materiality that we work
to the penultimate paragraph and with
materiality with assessed for accounts
or daughters of the council's financial
statements is not 0 point seven million
i think in and we've missed offer a
million and in presentation the Biggers
so i just wanted to make sure that we
and terrified that but on ya know poor
bill point seven pounds they thought it
was important to clarify that and just
just to give you an indication as well
as the amount of accuracy that we are
expecting to see in the production of
the council's financial statements um in
section 5 I think we can summarize that
information as that we are happy to be
able to communicate to you that we are
for the independent the council
therefore we can conduct our audit with
neither fear nor fader an impending say
on nine point 17 I would dearly love to
be able to tell you that we are and
massively more efficient than our
predecessors and have been able to give
you exactly the same work for a large
discounts I'm afraid the did the truth
is that this and the reduction the fees
was part of the the one of the last act
of the audit Commission when it retains
its audits to be able to make
efficiencies across a number of local
government bodies which are reflecting
the scale fees it extends so the fee in
comparison to previous the eighties
approximately twenty-five percent
reduction and but it does cover the same
amount of work the same amount of input
there's no reduction in the scope of the
coverage that we will be providing in
comparison to video
those are the key areas I want to pile
up to me having happy to take any
questions you might have thank you thank
you very much for coming I guess the
further simple question is a few
obviously only had limited time to look
at the whole cambio mr. Kandel is there
anything that I mean obviously with dbo
we we wouldn't expect you to find any
nasty surprises but is there anything
that has come to your attention to you
suddenly think will perhaps we should be
looking this little bit more clothes
than has been lost in the past or are
you reasonably comfortable present with
what you've seen and what you know and
the help from video and officers that
yeah okay we know what we've been
ourselves important we pretty much are
comfortable with what we what we're
seeing I think at this point in time
just planting the cauliflower
reinsurance we we have had no nasty
surprises and as I said in my
introduction the officers have made and
great efforts to give us the information
we've requested to their car we've had
access and to them and they've talked us
through their process is probably in
some cases in much more detail than we
ever need so nothing has come to our
attention at this point in time that we
would need to to bring to your attention
okay
think male Jim and the professional is
Benson another video where our auditors
470 yes have you been body for a set
period of time my brain we are appointed
until 2017-18 when at that point in time
under the local ordinate ability act for
the year eighteen nineteen you do have
the ability to choose your own auditors
that has been one of the key changes in
legislation around the local public
audits and the ability for councils down
to undertake that appointments process
so and we would likely to be around for
that period of time that's under the new
freedoms you will have in a couple of
years you will have to talk show me you
want us okay any other questions so the
recommendation is that the external
auditors annual time for 2015-16 be
noted
item 10 is the exclusion members of the
public we have come to the end of the
business that we can debate with you
present remaining report contains exempt
information and I would ask you to leave
the meeting here by resolves that under
section 184 of local government at 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following item of business on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph 3 of part 1 of
shedule 12a of the Act so we're now
turning off the recording okay item 11
yes numbers this item and emily is just
update of aldi recommendation oh sorry
completed audit and I mean which members
members of bread bakers will have the
state questions or do can give you a
break